so let's prove that theorem due to lfkn
that sharpshot decision is in ip
remember sharpshot decision is the
problem given a formula freezing formula
phi
and an integer k between zero to the n
decide if k is the number of satisfying
assignments for this formula phi
the proof of this result involves two
steps
first step is to take your boolean
formula
and turn it into an arithmetic
expression
convert it into an arithmetic formula
denoted by i sub phi
on the same n variables but now it's an
arithmetic formula so the variables can
assume
say integer values or values from some
large finite field
and as any arithmetic formula this this
one is computing some polynomial
and let's denote this polynomial
computed by a
by p sub phi of x1 for xn
and use as you shall see in the
transformation it will turn out that
this arithmetic formula will have
relatively small degree polynomial in
the size of the formula
this arithmetic formula will capture
the original 3c f5 in the following
sentence
on all the assignments 0 1 to the n
the formula and the polynomial p supply
will agree
okay so now instead of counting
the number of satisfying assignments of
the formula phi
we will count the number of
satisfying assignments for the
polynomial p sub phi
when we look at the summation over all
zero one assignments
and because we now work with polynomials
you'll see it will be easier for us
to use some algebraic properties of
polynomials
to get a randomized procedure that we
need to get the ib protocol
that will happen in stage two after we
did this conversion from
boolean formulas phi to arithmetic
formulas capital a sub phi
will give an ib protocol which given
such an arithmetic formula
a sub prime on end variables and the
value k
will verify that
the sum of the values p sub phi
over all boolean points uh is actually k
and because of this faithfulness of
between
p sub phi and phi this summation of the
polynomial p sub phi
over the boolean domain is the same as
the summation of the original formula
phi over the boolean domain
so the task of counting satisfying
assignments
of phi is captured by this
expression here
so these two stages will handle them
separately
let's start with the easier one the
arithmetization stage
so we want to convert a formula into a
polynomial
and here is another place
where the locality of computation is
going to be useful for us
again cook levin's theorem is what makes
this whole thing work
because because of of cook levin's
theorem
we can talk about three cnfs
as opposed to some very general kind of
expressions and any formula
any three cnf can be converted to a
polynomial using
the following recursive definition uh
you construct the polynomial formula for
formula phi
by induction a constant zero can be
mapped to
polynomial zero constant one to
polynomial one
a variable x is mapped to a polynomial x
you can see that this is faithful
over all the boolean domain of the
overall points in the boolean domain
the polynomial p sub phi and the formula
phi given by this transformation
agree with each other and then once you
have the base case
inductively you say well if you want to
construct
a polynomial expression for the formula
not psi
then just construct the polynomial p sub
psi
for formula psi and then construct the
new polynomial as
1 minus v sub psi
negation of the variable is 1 minus the
variable negation of the formula is 1
minus the polynomial for the formula
for the conjunction of two psi 1 and
type 2
convert each one to a polynomial
expression arithmetic
formula and then just multiply the
result into formulas
if psi 1 and psi 2 are both 1 on a
particular assignment
then the polynomials are both one and
the product of this polynomial is also
one if at least one of the formula psi
one and side two is zero then
the product of the two corresponding
polynomials will be zero
so so far so good for the or uh you
transform the or of psi1 and
orb psi2 into this longer expression
it seems very strange until you realize
that we can use de morgan's laws
and write taiwan or psi2 as
double negation of psi 1 or psi 2
and then by applying appropriate
negation loss you can write this as a
negation of
the expression the conjunction of not
psi 1
and knob psi 2 and then you can use
this rule and this rule to
get uh the desired expression written
here
so this is a generic transformation it
applies to any formula let's apply it to
a particular
clause in our 3cnf so if my clause is
like this
then by the transformation described i
get a polynomial corresponding to that
clause which i'll denote by p sub clause
equal to this expression 1 minus 1 minus
x times y times 1 minus z
and my 3 cnf is a conjunction of clauses
of size
3 like this one and
i will convert it into an arithmetic
formula which just converts each clause
to a polynomial piece of clause
and then multiplies all of these
polynomials together
well i will not actually open up my
brackets when i do the multiplication
because that will blow up the size of my
representation of the polynomial
exponentially
i will keep things as an arithmetic
formula to be succinct
so i have an arithmetic expression for
each one of these polynomials
p sub clause one piece of clause m and
i'll just write the new formula
arithmetic formula which will be the
product of
those individual piece of clause
formulas this way
the arithmetic formula that i'll get
will be compact
of size about m because i had m clauses
to begin with
and also i can bound the degree of the
polynomial if i were to open up the
brackets and compute this polynomial
in variables as the sum of all the
monomials
then you see that it's a product of
things which correspond to clauses and
each such polynomial p sub clause has
degree
three so you have each clause of degree
three
and if you multiply those polynomials
together there are m of them so the
total degree
is going to be 3 times m and
m is small because it's basically the
size of the formula phi
so degrees smaller than 3m for us means
small
okay so that it's part one
arithmetization where we
took a free cnf formula and constructed
an arithmetic
expression arithmetic formula of small
compact size
uh which has relatively small degree
those things will be imported late later
in a moment and
phi and this arithmetic expression a sub
5 reconstructed this way
agree with each other on all the points
in the boolean
domain so now we go to part two
of this proof where we need to give
an ib protocol for testing
equalities like this so let's look at
this equality on the left-hand side
we have the summation
over n variables and each variable goes
from zero to one
so it's an exponential summation we're
summing up overall
to the end points in the boolean cube
of the polynomial p sub phi which is
given to us as an arithmetic formula
so for each individual value x1 for xn
we can efficiently compute the value of
the polynomial piece of phi because we
have an arithmetic formula
so if you give me a sequence of values
for x 1 for x n i
the verifier now can compute the value
of this arithmetic formula or or piece
of phi on any given tuple
but i cannot do this exponential
summation of this arithmetic formula
because it's exponential
that's how many points i need to add up
and on the right hand side we have some
value k between 0 and to then
which are prover possibly cheating
prover claims to be the correct value
for this
exponential summation so what we're
going to do
is quantifier elimination where we think
of this
summation signs as quantifiers and we'll
apply each round where the round would
consist of
prover sending some stuff to the
verifier and verify
challenging the proofer approver by
sending some randomness
back so after each such exchange
one sigma sign will be dropped
okay so we'll start with the need to
check the equality of this expression
some number equal to this exponential
summation
where i have summation signs for each
of the n variables and some easily
computable
arithmetic formula expression for the
polynomial
to the new expression of the same type
some new number k prime on the left
and some expression which looks like a
bunch of summations
of some related but new polynomial
arithmetic formula p prime uh but note
that
i lost one summation of variable x1
so variable x1 is eliminated from the
polynomial p
prime and it's also eliminated from the
summation
so we're making progress and if we can
do this quantifier elimination in a
faithful way
such that you know we preserve the truth
and the truth of the original equality
in the next round
and if prover was cheating and was
lying to us then we would like also to
preserve the lie
of the provers so that in the next round
after this exchange
the prover is forced to prove something
that is wrong
if we can keep doing that for n rounds
then by the end of it we've eliminated
all the summation signs
and we're left with expression which has
a number on the left hand side
and some arithmetic formula on the right
hand side which has
no variables no free variables left so
this arithmetic expression
uh we can compute ourselves as the
verifier
and so the verifier after this
elimination of all the extension
of all this summation sign signs
can check in the last round
whether this equality is true or not
okay so at the beginning it's very
difficult then it becomes easier because
one summation sign is peeled off and
then after another round another
summation science sign is peeled off
and when all n of them are gone then the
problem to check is very easy for the
verifier
and they'll just do it at the end
the only thing the only tricky thing the
main thing the main part of the proof
is to ensure that we can go from start
to
double star dropping one quantifier
one summation sign in a nice way
preserving the truth and preserving the
falsehood
so this is what we're going to do almost
uh we'll show the following if the
initial
equation star equation was true
then after the exchange between the
approval and the verifier
uh the new equation that we'll get is
also going to be true with probability
one
okay remember the verifier will be used
random we'll be using randomness
so but with probability one the truth
will be preserved
on the other hand more interestingly if
they if the proverb was lying and
the equation star was incorrect so with
k is not the correct number of
satisfying assignments
then after the exchange the new equation
we get for k prime
will also be false not with probability
one but with probability of a close to
one with probability of
at least one minus some inverse
polynomial quantity
okay so what this means is that a lying
prover
is very likely forced to lie again
after we dropped one
summation sign and
the probability that a bad event happens
is that
when the approver was lying and then
fortunately for the prover at some point
it it ended up with the need to prove
the correct statement and now
it can be behave honestly from that
point on and make
our verifier incorrectly accept but the
probability
of our way fire verifier accepting
incorrectly
will be at most the probability that in
at least one of those
n rounds um the prover was able to
get away with the lie and the
probability that it gets away from
with the lie is only something like 1
over power 1 l and m
small and by the union bound the
probability that
in at least one of the n rounds the
approval will get away
with a y is at most the number of rounds
times the probability that
in each round in particular round the
prover gets away with his line
and that happens with probability n
times one over polyn
and it's going to be negligibly small
okay
so once we argue that this one round
works and satisfies these two conditions
will be done because then just repeat it
for
end rounds and use the union bound and
do the analysis
so let me focus on just a single round
first thing we're going to do is define
a special polynomial
in one variable q of x1
which is the polynomial we obtained from
this exponential summation
where you drop the summation over x1
but keep summing over x2 through xn
and now x1 is your free variable
even though this is exponential
summation if you think about it
as a polynomial it's a univariate
polynomial in variable x1 only
and moreover the degree of this
polynomial is at most the degree of the
original polynomial p
okay so polynomial q will have degree at
most 3m
because it's just the summation of
exponentially many
polynomial expression each of which is
of degree atmosphere
m and when you sum polynomials the
degree does not go up
by the definition of this polynomial q
it's not hard to see that if you add
q of zero and q of 1 then it's like
putting back the missing summation sign
here
summation over x1 so q0 plus q1 is just
the original summation
of px1 x2 xn over all points in the
boolean cube
which means that if the value k
is correct it's the actual number of
satisfying assignments
then the value k must be equal to q0
plus
q1 for the correct polynomial q
the way we defined okay
so what we're going to ask what we the
way if i are going to ask the prover to
do
is to send us the coefficients of this
polynomial
q the polynomial q has small degree
so the coefficients are few on the 3m of
them
and this polynomial amount of
information that the verifier can handle
so the proverb will send the
coefficients of some polynomial that
we'll call
f in variable x1 and the prover will
claim that
he sent us what we asked him for
namely the prover claims that f is
identically equal to
our polynomial q that we defined earlier
but
it may or may not be the case so f here
stands for fake so maybe
it's a fake polynomial it could be equal
to q if
prover is honest but it could if the
proverb is lying then it's probably not
going to be equal to q
so we shouldn't be trusting our program
okay so the first thing that the
verifier will do after receiving this
polynomial f is to check the condition
that we know should be satisfied in case
uh f and q are the same so the verifier
will check
if value k is equal to f0 plus f1
and if everything is was honest if k was
correct
and f is equal to q so prover is playing
honestly
and then of course this equality will be
satisfied
and if the proverb is trying to cheat
the and the equality is not satisfied so
if this is not equal
then the verifier knows that something
fishy is going on proverbs
cheating somewhere and the verifier will
reject in this case right away
without continuing to the next round
even
so proverb doesn't want to be
caught cheating so it will try to send
some polynomial f
such that it will pass this sum check
condition note that
suppose that the prover was wrong
was lying and the value k is incorrect
but the verifier did not catch
the prover at the lie yet meaning that
this equality k
equal to f of 0 plus f of 1 passed
okay so k is incorrect but k is equal to
f of 0 plus f of 1.
what does it mean it means that f and q
are not equal polynomials they're not
the same polynomials
because for q we know this equality is
not
true if k is incorrect
so what we're going to do now to get to
the next round
problem is define k prime to be
the value of the polynomial f that we
got from the prover
evaluated at a random point r in the
range
between 1 and 2 n
and the new polynomial p prime on
variables x2
through xn only will be defined as the
original polynomial p
where the first variable is frozen to be
this random
value random integer r this is by the
way where these arithmetic formulas are
useful to us because
if we had been working with boolean
formulas we could not replace
a boolean variable with a random integer
but because we have arithmetic formula
now
we can replace a variable x1 with a
random large integer r
by the definition it's not hard to see
that the summation of p prime
of the remain on the remaining variables
x2 3xn
is exactly the value of the polynomial q
the correct polynomial q
at point r so what's the probability
that k prime is equal to the summation
of p
prime what's the probability that in the
next round
the quantity k prime that we defined
here is equal to the summation of the
polynomial p
prime that we define here over the
remaining variables x 2 3 x m
well this is exactly the probability of
a randomly chosen
value r that f of r is equal to q of r
because k prime is equal to f of r and
the summation is equal to q of r
so the probability that from an
incorrect
equality k equal to the summation of p
we get correct equality k prime
equal to the summation of p prime is the
probability that
a random value r is such
that the two polynomials f and q which
are not the same
have the same value on this number r
and the probability of this happening is
going to be small
because if i have two distinct
polynomials two different polynomials of
degree at most 3m
the probability each one of them will
have
few roots in particular the difference
of the two polynomials f minus q
is another polynomial of degree at most
3m and polynomial universal polynomial
of degree at most 3m
has at most 3m roots so probability that
r randomly chosen is one of those
at most three of m three m roots is at
most 3m
divided by the range from which we're
picking this random r
so we're picking r between 1 and to the
n so there are two line possibilities
for r
there are only three m possibilities at
most for a root of the f minus q
polynomial
so that's for that's why the probability
that f is equal to q
on a randomly chosen number r is at most
three m over to n
remember m was polynomially small uh two
then is exponentially big
so three m over two then is negligible
and
it's little of 1 much smaller than 1
over n
square and that's the probability
of making a mistake and letting the
prover away with a lie
in one round okay and as i mentioned
before
we can do this for uh n rounds and the
probability that approver
will be able to get away with the lie in
at least one round
is going to be by the union bound is
much smaller than one
and that allows us to finish the
argument